quand je m'immerge dans le port de
marseille je mets un masque
ils sont tout doucement sous l'eau je
suis entouré de plastique de gants de
masques
je le descends le long des chaînes c'est
et les chaînes qui relie les bateaux sur
le fond du port pour les maintenir
et sur le fond c'est un amoncellement
dorin désert de vases un amoncellement
de canettes et de bouteilles en
plastique de trottinettes de vélo de
catic de cônes de signalisation 20 tous
qui a strictement rien faire sous l'eau
bon bah c'est inouï jazz c'est une
grande décharge allant des simples
marseille
en
depuis je suis enfant fasciné par
l'océan par ce qui s'y passe et par tous
le monde de l'exploration sous marine
j'en ai fait mon métier je photographe
photojournaliste s'est spécialisé dans
ce monde qui le monde sous marin
j'ai la chance de vivre dans un des plus
bel endroit du monde c'est la bête
marseille dans un petit port qui
s'appelle le port des goudes c'est un
endroit absolument merveilleux il est
soumis aux à ces grands grands courants
qui alimentent ces deux baies et depuis
le web depuis quelques années ben la
situation elle se dégrade réellement et
je vois en fait cette abondance de
macrodéchets de dégueulasserie de
stupidité je passe ya besoin de beaucoup
commentée pour comprendre ce qui se
passe quand on est en plein coeur du
paris des calanques entre les goudes
ces villages de calonges il ya des
milieux déchets emballages à usage
unique
ils sont partout il n'y a pas de
poubelle pour son lait collecté ici la
restauration la pile semaine dans le
vert partout où tu as déjà le club des
sacs plastiques du continent
alimentaires usagées ça je sais pas
combien de temps ça amène à se roder
c'était pas ça et là voilà roth un stock
de médicaments sais pas pourquoi c'est
seulement tombé du camion inclus pour
traquer un antalgique très puissant
parce que ça peut faire la c9 en plus
c'est des bouteilles des bouteilles des
bouteilles en plastique voilà évident
tous les déchets qu'on a vu
dès qu'il ya du vent et finissent la mer
c'est ne peut par le cercle non vertueux
renonceront à facettes on va aller dans
l'eau on va longer toute la côte
[Musique]
on va le vacarme de forme mieux on va
les voir impossible
j'aime expliquer c'est comment
fonctionne avec berné commun
dans la question gect
radio et on arrive sur la partie
marqué au silence
[Musique]
souvent ici de déchets qui arrivent
d'italie
pour ici
après midi nous
c'est très très beau l'extérieur et on
va voir sous un petit peu différente
[Musique]
par exemple de ce jardin les emballages
alimentaires la paix du placis pense que
nettoyer ses passes et utopique temps
qu'on n'arrête pas d'alimenter la mer et
l'océan de ça c'est un 25 2
ça rentre un moment ou un autre quand ça
c'est ça s'est délité en microfibre
microplastiques dans de son animateur
combat le bouffer on va se faire bouffer
nos enfants il ya des vidéos qui ont été
faites la berner par l'ifremer très
profond à plus de mille mètres de
profondeur au large de toulon et on voit
un spectacle affligeant de ces décharges
amer ouverte retrouve exactement la même
chose qu'en faible profondeur
[Musique]
des charges comme sa part de 1000 mètres
de fond je pense que c'est
inenvisageable de nettoyer quoi que ce
soit à la base le matériau plastique les
faits pour durer très longtemps et
c'était une notion d'écologie génial en
fait de dire j'ai un produit il va durer
très longtemps et en fait on l'a
détourné et c'est devenu un matériau à
usage unique est la principale qualité
du plastique aujourd'hui est devenu son
principal défaut c'est de durer très
longtemps
[Musique]
pose aujourd'hui sincèrement la question
du niveau de conscience qu'on a parce
qu'on en parle tous on a par tous très
bien on est tous témoins et je vois la
situation se dégrader y'a pas longtemps
je lis l'article de journal scientifique
ça ernst sur la pollution plastique sur
ses calculs mathématiques qui annonce 3
fois plus de déchets dans l'océan d'ici
comment c'est possible d'avoir
conscience d'être continuer
[Musique]